we're taking you back now to the World
Economic Forum in Davos where Donald
Trump is now seated on the stage and
expected to speak right now we just
watch the introduction of Donald Trump
of course a lot of anticipation around
this speech he's also facing impeachment
trial beginning in the Senate in the
United States let's have a listen very
special congratulations on your 50th
year hosting the annual meeting of the
World Economic Forum a truly amazing
achievement it's an honor to address the
distinguished members of this
organization for the second time as
president when I spoke at this forum two
years ago I told you that we had
launched the great American comeback
today I'm proud to declare that the
United States is in the midst of an
economic boom the likes of which the
world has never seen before we've
regained our stride we discovered our
spirit and reawakened the powerful
machinery of American Enterprise
America's thriving America's flourishing
and yes America is winning again like
never before just last week alone the
United States concluded two
extraordinary trade deals the agreement
with China and the United States Mexico
Canada agreement the two biggest trade
deals ever made they just happened to
get done in the same week these
agreements represent a new model of
trade for the 21st century agreements
that are fair reciprocal and that
prioritize the needs of workers and
families America's economic turnaround
has been nothing short of spectacular
when I took office three years ago
America's economy was in a rather dismal
state under the previous administration
nearly 200,000 manufacturing jobs had
vanished wages were flat or falling
almost 5 million more Americans had left
the labor force than had gotten jobs and
more than 10 million people
had been added to the Food Stamp rolls
the experts predicted a decade of very
very slow growth or maybe even negative
growth high unemployment and a dwindling
workforce and very much a shrinking
middle class millions of hardworking
ordinary citizens felt neglected
betrayed forgotten they were rapidly
losing faith in the system before my
presidency began the outlook for many
nations was bleak top economists warned
of a protracted worldwide recession the
World Bank lowered its projections for
global growth to a number that nobody
wanted to even think about pessimism had
taken root deep in the minds of leading
thinkers business leaders and policy
makers yet despite all of the cynics I
had never been more confident in
America's future I knew we were on the
verge of a profound economic resurgence
if we did things right
one that would generate a historic wave
of investment wage growth and job
creation I knew that if we unleash the
potential of our people if we cut taxes
slashed regulations and we did that at a
level that's never been done before in
the history of our country in a short
period of time
fix broken trade deals and fully tapped
American energy that prosperity would
come thundering back at a record speed
and that is exactly what we did and that
is exactly what happened since my
election America has gained over 7
million jobs a number unthinkable I
wouldn't say it I wouldn't talk about it
but that was a number that I had in mind
the projection was 2 million we did
seven more than three times the
government's own projections the
unemployment rate is now less than three
point five percent and at 3.5%
that's a number that is the lowest in
more than 50 years the average
unemployment rate from my administration
is the lowest for any US president in
recorded history we started off with
reasonably high rate for the first time
in decades we are no longer simply
concentrating wealth in the hands of a
few we're concentrating and creating the
most inclusive economy ever to exist we
are lifting up Americans of every race
color religion and Creed unemployment
rates among African Americans Hispanic
Americans and Asian Americans have all
reached record lows African American
youth unemployment has reached the
lowest it's ever been in the history of
our country African American poverty has
plummeted to the lowest rate ever
recorded the unemployment rate for women
reached the lowest level since 1953 and
women now comprise a majority of the
American workforce that's for the first
time the unemployment rate for veterans
has dropped to a record low the
unemployment rate for disabled Americans
has reached an all-time record low
workers without a high school diploma
have achieved the lowest unemployment
rate recorded in US history
wages are rising across the board and
those at the bottom of the income ladder
are enjoying the percentage by far
largest gains workers wages are now
growing faster than management wages
earnings growth for the bottom 10% is
outpacing the top 10% something that has
not happened paychecks for high school
graduates are rising faster than for
college graduates young Americans just
entering the workforce are also sharing
in America's extraordinary prosperity
since I took office more than 2 million
Millennials
have gotten jobs and their wages have
grown by nearly 5% annually a number
that was unthinkable nobody would have
ever thought it was possible three years
ago a record number of Americans between
the ages of 25 and 34 are now working in
the eight years before I took office
over 300,000 working age people left the
workforce in just three years of my
administration 3.5 million people have
joined the work force 10 million people
have been lifted off welfare in less
than 3 years celebrating the dignity of
work is a fundamental pillar of our
agenda this is a blue-collar boom since
my election the net worth of the bottom
half of wage earners has increased by
plus 47 percent three times faster than
the increase for the top one percent
real median household income is at the
highest level ever recorded the American
Dream is back bigger better and stronger
than ever before
no one is benefitting more than
America's middle class we have created
1.2 million manufacturing and
construction jobs a number also
unthinkable after losing 60,000
factories under the previous two
administrations hard to believe when you
hear 60,000 factories America has now
gained in a very short period of time
12,000 new factories under my
administration and the numbers going up
rapidly will be beating the 60,000
number that we lost except these will be
bigger newer and the latest years of
economic stagnation have given way to a
roaring geyser of opportunity u.s. stock
markets have soared by more than 50
percent since my election adding more
than 19 trillion dollars to household
wealth and boosting
401 k's pensions and college savings
accounts for millions of hard-working
families and these great numbers are
many things and it's despite the fact
that the Fed has raised rates too fast
and lowered them too slowly and even now
as the United States is by far the
strongest economic power in the world
it's not even close who's going to be
close but a lot of good things happened
to us and some not so good things happen
to certain to other places they're
forced to compete and we compete with
nations that are getting negative rates
something very new meaning they get paid
to borrow money something that I could
get used to very quickly love that kind
of payback you alone know how much am I
getting nevertheless we still have the
best numbers that we've had in so many
different areas it's a conservative
approach and we have a tremendous upside
potential we have not even started
because the numbers were talking about
our massive the time for skepticism is
over people are flowing back into our
country companies are coming back into
our country many of you who I know are
coming back in with your plants and your
factories thank you very much America's
newfound prosperity is undeniable
unprecedented and unmatched anywhere in
the world America achieved this stunning
turnaround not by making minor changes
to a handful of policies but by adopting
a whole new approach centered entirely
on the well-being of the American worker
every decision we make on taxes trade
regulation energy immigration education
and more is focused on improving the
lives of everyday Americans we are
determined to create the highest
standard of living that anyone can
imagine
and right now that's what we're doing
for our workers the highest in the world
and we're determined to ensure that the
working and middle class
reap the largest gains a nation's
highest duty is to its own citizens
honoring this truth is the only way to
build faith and confidence in the market
system only when governments put their
own citizens first will people be fully
invested in their national futures in
the United States we're building an
economy that works for everyone
restoring the bonds of love and loyalty
that unites citizens and powers Nations
today I hold up the American model as an
example to the world of a working system
of free enterprise that will produce the
most benefits for the most people in the
21st century and beyond a pro worker pro
citizen pro-family agenda demonstrates
how a nation can thrive when its
communities its companies its government
and its people work together for the
good of the whole nation as part of this
new vision we passed the largest package
of tax cuts and reforms in American
history we double the child tax credit
benefiting 40 million American families
and lifting 650,000 single mothers and
their 1 million children out of poverty
and out of poverty quickly we passed the
first ever tax credit for employers who
provide paid paternal leave for
employees earning 72,000 dollars or less
annually and past paid family leave for
government employees as a model for the
country we made childcare much more
affordable and reduced or eliminated
childcare wait lists all across the
nation our child care reforms are
supporting working parents and ensuring
their children have access to
high-quality care and education all of
which they very much deserve we lowered
our business tax from the highest in the
developed world down to one that's not
only competitive but one of the lower
taxes we created nearly
9,000 opportunity zones and distressed
communities where capital gains or
long-term investments are now taxed at
zero and tremendous wealth is pouring
into areas that for a hundred years or
nothing
the thirty-five million Americans who
live in these areas have already seen
their home values rise by more than
twenty two billion dollars my
administration has also made historic
investments in historically black
colleges and universities
I saved HB c u--'s we save them they
were going out and we saved them we're
removing roadblocks to success and
rewarding businesses that invest in
workers families and communities we've
also launched the most ambitious
campaign in history to reduce
job-killing regulations for every new
regulation adopted we are removing eight
old regulations which will save an
average of American households about
$3,100 per year it was going to be for
every one we do - but we were able to
lift that - aid and we think that's
going to go quite a bit higher we still
have a way to go today I urge other
nations to follow our example and
liberate your citizens from the crushing
weight of bureaucracy with that you have
to run your own countries the way you
want we are also restoring the
constitutional rule of law in America
which is essential to our economy our
liberty and our future and that's why
we've appointed over 190 federal judges
a record to interpret the law as written
190 federal judges think of that in two
Supreme Court judges as a result of our
efforts investment is pouring into our
country in the first half of 2019 the
United States attracted nearly
one-quarter of all foreign direct
investment in the world think of that 25
percent of all foreign investment all
over the world came in
to the United States and that numbers
increasing rapidly to every business
looking for a place where they are free
to invest build thrive innovate and
succeed there is no better place on
earth than the United States as a
central part of our commitment to
building an inclusive society we
established the National Council for the
American worker we want every citizen
regardless of age or background to have
the cutting-edge skills to compete and
succeed in tomorrow's workplace this
includes critical industries like
artificial intelligence quantum
computing and 5g under Ivanka's
leadership who's with us today our
pledge to America's workers has become a
full-blown national movement with over
400 companies committing to provide new
job and training opportunities to
already very close to 15 million
American students and workers 15 million
America is making sweeping changes to
place workers and their families at the
center of our national agenda perhaps
the most transformative change of all is
on trade reform where we're addressing
chronic problems that have been ignored
tolerated or enabled for decades our
leaders did nothing about what happened
to us on trade before I was elected
China's predatory practices were
undermining trade for everyone but no
one did anything about it except allow
it to keep getting worse and worse and
worse under my leadership America
confronted the problem head-on under our
new phase 1 agreement phase 2 is
starting negotiations very shortly
China has agreed to substantially do
things that they would not have done
measures to protect intellectual
property stop forced technology
transfers remove trade barriers and
agricultural goods and on agricultural
Goods where we were treated so badly
open its financial sector totally that's
done and maintain a stable currency all
backed by very very strong enforcement a
relationship with China right now has
probably never been better we went
through a very rough patch but it's
never ever been better my relationship
with President Xi is an extraordinary
one he's for China out for the US but
other than that we love each other
additionally China will spend an
additional two hundred billion dollars
over two years on American services
agriculture and energy and manufactured
goods so we'll be taken in in excess of
200 billion could be closer to 300
billion when it finishes but these
achievements would not have been
possible without the implementation of
tariffs which we had to use and we're
using them on others too and that is why
most of our tariffs on China will remain
in place during the Phase two
negotiations for the most part the
tariffs have been left and were being
paid billions and billions of dollars a
year as a country as I mentioned earlier
we ended the NAFTA disaster one of the
worst trade deals ever made
not even close and replaced it with the
incredible new trade deal the u.s. MCA
that's Mexico and Canada in the nearly
25 years after NAFTA the United States
lost one in four manufacturing jobs
including nearly one in four vehicle
manufacturing jobs it was an incentive
to leave the country the NAFTA agreement
exemplified the decades-long failures of
the international trading system the
agreement shifted wealth to the hands of
a few promoted massive outsourcing drove
down wages and shuttered plants and
factories by the thousands the plants
would leave our country make the product
sell it into our country we ended up
with no jobs and no taxes would buy
other country's product that doesn't
happen anymore this is the wreckage that
I was elected to
clean up it's probably the reason I ran
for president more than any other thing
because I couldn't understand why we
were losing all of these jobs to other
countries at such a rapid rate and it
got worse and worse and I think it's
probably the primary reason that I ran
but there are other reasons also and to
replace with a new system that puts
workers before the special interests and
the special interests will do just fine
but the workers come first our brand new
u.s. MCA is the result of the broadest
coalition ever assembled for Trade
Agreement manufacturing agriculture and
labor all strongly endorsed the deal and
as you know it just passed in Congress
overwhelmingly it shows how to solve the
21st century challenge we we all face
protecting intellectual property
expanding digital trade we shoring lost
jobs and ensuring rising wages and
living standards the United States has
also concluded a great new trade deal
with Japan approximately 40 billion
dollars and completely renegotiated our
deal with South Korea we're also
negotiating many other transactions with
many other countries and we look forward
to negotiating a tremendous new deal
with the United Kingdom have a wonderful
new prime minister once very much to
make a deal as they say to protect our
security and our economy we are also
boldly embracing American energy
independence the United States is now by
far the number one producer of oil and
natural gas anywhere in the world by far
it's not even close
while many European countries struggle
with crippling energy costs the American
energy revolution is saving American
families $2,500 every year in lowering
electric bills and numbers that people
said couldn't happen and also very
importantly prices at the pump we've
been so successful that the
it states no longer needs to import
energy from hostile nations with an
abundance of American natural gas now
available our European allies no longer
have to be vulnerable to unfriendly
energy suppliers either we urge our
friends in Europe to use America's vast
supply and achieve true energy security
with US companies and researchers
leading the way we are on the threshold
of virtually unlimited reserves of
energy including from traditional fuels
LNG clean coal next generation nuclear
power and gas hydrate technologies at
the same time I'm proud to report the
United States is among the cleanest air
and drinking water on earth and we're
going to keep it that way and we just
came out with a report that at this
moment it's the cleanest it's been in
the last 40 years we're committed to
conserving the majesty of God's creation
and the natural beauty of our world
today I am pleased to announce the
United States will join 1 trillion trees
initiative being launched here at the
World Economic Forum 1 trillion trees
and in doing so we will continue to show
strong leadership and restoring growing
and better managing our trees and our
forests this is not a time for pessimism
this is a time for optimism fear and
doubt is not a good thought process
because this is a time for tremendous
hope and joy and optimism and action but
to embrace the possibilities of tomorrow
we must reject the perennial prophets of
doom and their predictions of the
Apocalypse
they are the heirs of yesterday's
foolish fortune tellers and I have them
and you have them and we all have them
and they want to see us too badly but we
don't let that happen they predicted an
overpopulation crisis in the 1960s mass
starvation and the seventies and an end
of oil in the 1990s these alarmists
always demand the same thing absolute
power to dominate transform and control
every aspect of our lives we will never
let radical socialists destroy our
economy wreck our country or eradicate
our liberty America will always be the
proud strong and unyielding bastion of
freedom in America we understand what
the pessimists refused to see that a
growing and vibrant market economy
focused on the future lifts the human
spirit and excites creativity strong
enough to overcome any challenge any
challenge by far the great scientific
breakthroughs of the 20th century from
penicillin to high-yield wheat to modern
transportation and breakthrough vaccines
have lifted living standards and saved
billions of lives around the world and
we're continuing to work on things that
you'll be hearing about in the near
future that even today sitting here
right now you wouldn't believe it's
possible that we have found the answers
you'll be hearing about it but we have
found answers to things that people say
would not be possible certainly not in a
very short period of time but the
wonders of the last century will pale in
comparison to what today's young
innovators will achieve because they are
doing things that nobody thought even
feasible to begin we continue to embrace
technology not to shun it when people
are free to innovate millions will live
longer happier healthier lives for three
years now America has shown the world
that the path to a prosperous future
begins with putting workers first
choosing growth and freeing
entrepreneurs to bring their dreams to
life for anyone who doubts what is
possible in the future we need only look
at the towering achievements of the past
only a few hundred miles from here
are some of the great cities of Europe
teeming centres of Commerce and culture
each of them is full of reminders of
what human Drive and imagination can
achieve centuries ago at the time of the
Renaissance skilled craftsmen and
laborers looked upwards and built the
structures that still touch the human
heart to this day some of the greatest
structures in the world have been built
hundreds of years ago in Italy the
citizens once started construction on
what would be a 140 year project the
Duomo of Florence credible credible
place while the technology did not yet
exist to complete their design city
fathers forged ahead anyway certain that
they would figure it out someday these
citizens of Florence did not accept
limits to their high aspirations and so
the great dome was finally built in
France another century long project
continues to halt such a grip on our
hearts and our souls that even 800 years
after its construction
when the Cathedral of Notre Dom was
engulfed in flames last year such a sad
sight to watch unbelievable sight
especially for those of us that
considered it one of the great great
monuments and representing so many
different things the whole world grieved
through her sanctuary now stands
scorched and charred and a sight that's
hard to believe when you got used to it
to look at it now hard to believe but we
know that no true DOM will be restored
will be restored magnificently the great
bells will once again ring out for all
to hear
giving glory to God and filling Millions
with Wonder and all the cathedrals of
Europe teach us to pursue big dreams
daring adventures and unbridled
ambitions they urge us to consider not
only what we build today but what we
will endure long after we are gone they
testify to the power of ordinary people
to realize extraordinary achievements
when United by a grand and noble purpose
so together we must go forward with
confidence determination and vision we
must not be timid or meek or fearful but
instead we must boldly seize the day and
embrace the moment we have so many great
leaders in this room not only business
leaders but leaders of nations and some
are doing such a fantastic job we work
together very closely we will draw a
strength from the glories of the past
and we will make greatness our common
mission for the future together we will
make our nations stronger our countries
safer our culture richer our people
freer and the world more beautiful than
ever before above all else we will
forever
be loyal to our workers or citizens and
our families the men and women who are
the backbone of our economies the heart
of our communities and the soul of our
countries let us bring light to their
lives one by one and empower them to
light up the world
thank you very much god bless you god
bless your countries and god bless
america
thank you thank you very much
well if you're just joining us you've
been listening to US president Donald
Trump addressing global leaders and
businesspeople in the Swiss Alps for
making headline remarks at the World
Economic Forum in Davos well he's been
emphasizing his achievements when it
comes to the American economy as well as
various trade deals as well as also
saying the country's relationship with
China has never been better
he's also been pushing back on what he
calls the perennial prophets of doom and
their predictions of the apocalypse well
I believe he's about to take some
questions so let's go back and listen in
injecting optimism into our discussions
we have many problems in the world but I
think we need as you said we need dreams
and we have all the capabilities
technology leadership to realize so
screams so thank you again mr. president
for having joined us here at the opening
of C 50th anniversary of the World
Economic Forum
[Applause]
well it appears that he is not going to
be taking questions so let's dig into a
little more of this without diplomatic
editor James BAE's who joins us now live
from Davos James you've been listening
in to this speech so no surprises there
then and how is he likely to be received
well certainly very politely by the
audience here he's the first speaker at
this year's 50th World Economic Forum
here in Davos this was the special
address the first formal big session
taking place here at Davos quite a
predictable speech in many ways politely
received by the audience and I think the
speech was a very bullish speech about
the US economy and the audience very
much people back at home on this day
that is the day in a few hours time that
the impeachment trial will start in
Washington DC
there were many including myself who
thought perhaps at the last minute he
was going to postpone this trip but
advisors I think in the White House said
it was a good day to be on the world
stage it was a good day to sound
presidential and a speech full of facts
I'm sure some of the campaign
fact-checkers who already have started
their work will be going through those
facts with a fine-tooth comb to see
whether they agree that they all
actually are true let's discuss what we
heard in that speech further with our
guest
it's rachel kite she's the Dean of the
Fletcher School for international
affairs first your take on what he said
well I it was a very assertive speech
about the success that he believes he
has brought to the US economy since
coming to office it was also a speech
about optimism that you know sort of a
can-do attitude probably at odds with a
sort of global view that there are some
really fundamental problems we have to
grapple with and that's what Davos Davos
man diverse woman is trying to get their
arms around this week a whole list of
facts there I'm not going to ask you to
do the fact-checking here but some of
them are going to be contentious well I
think that the focus here at Davos
is that our economies are becoming
less inclusive and the IMF and others
have come out with data that shows that
that's the case including in the United
States so I think juxtaposing what he
believes is the success rate he's having
in sort of helping American workers and
people on low income with that data
around inclusion is something to look at
and then secondly of course the other
big threat that everybody is talking
about and already this morning all my
meetings with business have been about
how do we decarbonize this economy so it
works for everyone
not any mention of that and in that hall
we believe we certainly saw her go in
greta tunberg was in the hall
we didn't Davos the cameras there that
are provided by the World Economic Forum
focus only on the speaker so we didn't
see her reaction but I suspect he did
talk about the environment and paste a
very rosy picture of what the US is
doing I suspect she's going to be
skeptical about that well I think a lot
of people are because the message here
from business and from Greta and others
is that we have got no time to lose in
fact we've got to double down on this
and that requires governments to really
ratchet up their ambition he talked
about the technological prowess in the
energy sector in the United States
absolutely but that has to be used to
decarbonize the energy sector really
quickly and yes he agreed to join one
trillion trees that's a good thing
planting a trillion trees helps suck
carbon out of the atmosphere but you got
to stop putting it up there in the first
place as well he seems to like it here
he came here two years ago and he was
very positive about Davos likes being
part of this Club worth reminding people
that he never was invited to speak as a
business leader only since he's been
president tell me though your meetings
your private conversations I don't want
to know who said what do they think of
him well I think the world is preparing
for a second Trump term and what does
that mean while also thinking about what
does it mean if there's policy reversal
with a Democrat coming to to power at
the end of the year and I think that one
of the things everybody is focused on
here is uncertainty there's a velocity
of change which we've never seen before
we have major problems that require
international coordination international
cooperation immigration climate change
zoo notic diseases the news from China
today and this America first I'm taking
care of my people works let the fact
checkers check but it's it's kind of a
tonal with regard to sort of the
atmosphere here at Davos Rachel kite
Dean of the Fletcher School thank you
for joining us here on al Jazeera worth
noting as well the one word that wasn't
in that speech any moment and that is
the word impeachment and obviously
you're watching this on in on al Jazeera
we're giving you the international
context of this but I can tell you if
you're watching a US domestic news
channel they talk about nothing else he
didn't mention the big thing that's
happening in just a few hours James
BAE's there live for us across all the
events in Davos thank you James well
plenty going on in the Swiss Alps and as
James was just saying Donald Trump is in
Davos but at the same time after months
of arguments and build-up his
impeachment trial is set to begin in the
Senate later on Tuesday
well Mara Marwan Bashara is al jazeera
senior political analyst and he's here
to talk us through it all so Marwan
presumably a distraction tactic here on
trump's part talking economics while the
Democrats are trying to remove him from
office absolutely
I guess as James were saying the the big
elephant in the room was impeachment
it's not mentioned by the president but
it's in everyone's mind but that's it
that's exactly why he is in Davos I
think it's not only to make the big
contrast between what the Democrats are
doing as far as he's concerned stabbing
the president in the back or what he is
doing being presidentials speaking
boasting lecturing the world business
and political leaders about America's
greatness and what domestic audience
presumably as well absolutely and here
where I think it's not just a contrast
here's where the antidote is the
antidote to the impeachment is Davos in
as far as Trump is concerned because
what he just did there
you know our correspondent Kyle call it
facts I'll call it claims because I can
do neither analyst
Trump's claims about the American
economy and a lot of them might be true
he of course they are selectively facts
whatever facts there are among them
there are selectively facts because he
didn't speak about deficit or that debt
and so on so forth but build as it may
Davos comes as as far as his concern has
an antidote to the impeachment because
once again we see the proof the
demonstration that no one can Trump
Trump in as far as Trump
trumpeting for Trump I just thought
about that I was listening to him I want
to dig in a little bit into the
impeachment itself because today we're
hearing from senator Mitch McConnell
about the rules of the impeachment and I
mean he's obviously trying to keep this
of it would be a very very speedy trial
and he's trying to justify it I believe
based on Clinton's impeachment trying to
say that the rules were very similar no
apparently not the rules are not very
similar he's really presenting a whole
other way of approaching this he wants
it to be quick and of course a lot of
people are looking at this to be an
unfair process because of the collusion
between the Senate leader and the
president and it's very difficult to run
a court a process an impeachment process
with the Supreme Court judge presiding
over it while at the same time you are
coordinating the step with the White
House was explicitly that's what he's
doing
yes but so the idea is now there's a
that there are a few phases within this
quick process where there going to be a
vote whether it's vote about evidence or
what about new witnesses and so on so
forth if the four moderate Republicans
of Utah of Maine and what-have-you if
they decide that they will vote with the
Democrats then we might see something
interesting in terms of a process going
on forward witness is being called new
evidence being put in and then a more
robust discussion that would not be the
pleasure of the White House but if they
don't if these moderate Republicans
don't actually flip then we could
potentially see this all wrapped up
before the State of the Union next month
absolutely we were thinking about two
weeks now it's less than that while
we're talking about one day for this
party another day for that party
third day for discussion a fourth day
for discussing the evidence and
witnesses and maybe it'll be wrapped up
right after that
well obviously the Democrats want this
to play out very very differently so
what are their options now could they
try to change the rules once Mitch
McConnell has put them on the table oh
absolutely not I mean what they've done
in the democratic-controlled Congress
House of Representative they've done now
in the Senate where the Republicans
control the only way the Democrats can
affect anything if is if the for
moderate Republicans so-called moderate
Republicans meaning the ones who
actually want a process to take forward
because they think this is a government
of laws not of people no one is above
the law and they want to hear the
evidence not because they are probably
they are sure that there isn't a 2/3
majority to impeach them but at least
let's have a process that is credible
that is legitimate so that American can
be proud of its laws rather than let
this thing pass in the dark within two
three four or five days and then not be
proud of this very legal process that
America invented to put its leaders
under scrutiny well it will be treating
all of this with a huge amount of
scrutiny in the coming days
my one Bashara there our political
analysts thank you for joining me here
today in the studio